good morning everyone and welcome to the
12th Columbia library symposium for
those of you who don't know me I'm Damon
Jagger's on the interim vice provost and
university librarian here at Columbia
before we get started I wanted to take a
few minutes to thank the individuals who
have made this event possible Jane
winland our intrepid director of science
and engineering libraries organized the
event with a very hardworking team of
librarians and staff from across the
libraries that includes Elizabeth call
to being Hong Christy klon Meredith
Levin and Ellie ransom I'd like to give
them a little rabbit are any of you any
of you who have attempted to put on an
event like this knows how much work it
is and this little bit of recognition is
certainly well deserved I'd also like to
thank the sponsors for our this year's
events they are listed in your program
on the last page I won't go through each
of them there are representatives from
several here today so if you get a
chance speak with them and thank them
for the support for the event last I'd
like to thank the speakers and panelists
we have individuals who traveled from
near and far lots of folks from the
region but people who came from across
the country to participate today and
it's a really a stellar line-up and the
large crowd we have here today is
testament to that any success we have
today is really due to the the really no
small part to the their willingness to
participate in this event so
preemptively let's give a half so so now
I'd like to welcome you all to Colombia
so welcome and what for what we really
hope is an engaging may be provocative
event a gathering inspired by the
working career of someone who's both
professionally and personally important
to so many of us James Neal
so in thinking about what I might talk
about about Jim what a key I was
thinking about you know you might have
noticed when I when I need to introduce
myself there's this interim in my title
and that interim really denotes the fact
that I'm the poor sap attempting to
follow Jim as university librarian here
at Columbia even if it's just
temporarily and though Jim stepped down
three months ago his presence and
influence live on in the organization
that he led for over a decade in the
mini projects that we continue that he
initiated and even in his old office in
which I've taken up temporary residence
now jim was fantastic when he was
preparing to step down and he did his
best to tie up loose ends and clear the
decks but he did leave me this for those
of you who have met with Jim over the
years you know that this bust of Franz
Kafka sits like a sentinel looming over
the conference table in his office it's
large imposing I find it somewhat brutal
and I've often wondered really what the
hell was Jim trying to convey by placing
this thing where he did in his office
because all of you probably know little
Jim does happens by accident so over the
years I've wondered if this thing was
some comment on the kafka esque nature
of working at columbia is it about the
alienation that can be felt when working
in a massive bureaucratic institution
but no I decided that's really too
cynical for Jim I wondered if he was
just a big fan of Kafka's work is he a
fan of dung beetles or does he just
liked the idea of this imposing statue
looming over his meetings keeping us
honest as it were but I decided in the
end that's it's none of those things I
think the kafka busque and its placement
in such a prominent place a space were
so many of the decisions affecting the
direction of his organization were made
was really an admonition for those of us
in the room to always focus on what
truly matters to focus on the things
that are existentially important to
work and future of academic libraries
and their role in higher education to
focus on what we are as a profession and
what we should be as a profession to
always focus on the real impactful
actions that will advance our library
organizations in our parent institutions
that's what jim has done throughout his
career and that's what we want to do
today in a kind of reflection of his
working career so the plan for today is
not to roll people out one after another
to rehash this stellar highlights of
gems career when we talked about having
a theme of his career as for the
symposium he was not interested in doing
anything like that the plan is to focus
on several areas where Jim worked
actively and made important
contributions where he had lasting
impact on libraries and the profession
of librarianship we pulled out four of
those areas of the many we could have
information policy the evolving library
workforce leveraging grant funding to
spur innovation and libraries and the
relative efficacy of strategic planning
our goal is to have an engaging
provocative discussion amongst our
panelists and with all of you so please
be prepared with your questions and your
comments and maybe just maybe we'll get
Jim to tell us what this crazy thing is
all about so let's get started James G
Neal was named university librarian
emeritus here at Columbia after stepping
down as vice president for information
services and university librarian at the
end of 2014 prior to leading Columbia's
libraries he led the research libraries
in both Johns Hopkins and Indiana
University's he currently serves on the
OCLC board the Ala Council and he just
finished a term as a la treasurer over
the years he has served as a RL
president chair of the research
libraries group chair of nice oh and on
the boards of the freedom to read
Foundation and the digital preservation
network among many many others if you
want to blow an afternoon go to his
website and spend a little time with his
Vita he has authored scores of articles
for the professional literature and has
been recognized with just about every
award our profession offers including
the ACRL academic librarian of the year
the hue Atkinson memorial award and the
melvil Dewey metal and Jim is also
coined his share of terms for our
profession that you might recognize
including radical collaboration father I
think I think aunt helped him with that
one feral professionals and my personal
favorite the age of polygamy maybe we
can get him to explain that one later
too please join me in welcoming Jenn
meale to the podium
good morning this is a bit overwhelming
and to be honest somewhat awkward but I
will say it's an honor and privilege to
reflect on 42 years of service to the
academic and professional communities I
do understand how opportunity and fate
do play a role in a career but I
especially value great colleagues who
make such a difference in one's life
many of those colleagues are here today
and for that I am deeply grateful I have
always advanced the importance of vision
a sense of direction a sense of purpose
reaching for a position of distinction
and leadership but I've also recognized
that this is really insufficient as Marx
instructed us and I mean Carl and not
Groucho ideas have no value unless they
are translated into action he also makes
the important distinction and his work
between quantitative change and
qualitative change he uses the metaphor
of the pot of water over a flame the
temperature increasing but only when it
reaches a critical point the boiling
point when the liquid changes to gas
does a true transformation take place
this was his revolution what do I mean
by transformation to change in
composition or structure what we are and
what we do to change in outward form or
appearance how we are viewed and
understood and to change in character or
condition how we do it it is a
combination of shifts in our vision in
how we are perceived and valued and in
our practices and priorities I'm going
to try to cover this morning for ideas
in some brief remarks first I want to
talk about the evolving but
schizophrenic vision of academic
libraries
second I will posit a quick theory of
academic library past present and future
I'd like to identify several trends that
we are they're having a very critical
impact on academic library development
and lastly I'd like to list some not all
but some priority actions that will help
to sustain us and grow our relevance
value and impact and hopefully through
that conversation to lace in some oldie
but goodie humor the vision it was the
astrophysicist Carl Sagan who noted that
in order to make a great apple pie you
must first create the universe what do I
mean by vision we will be legacy we
academic library we will be legacy we
will be responsible for centuries of
societal records in all formats we will
be infrastructure the essential
combination of space technology systems
and expertise we will be repository
ensuring the long-term availability and
usability of our intellectual cultural
and scientific output we will be
platform serving as a sophisticated and
intelligent gateway to an expanding
array of multimedia interactive content
and tools we will be enterprise much
more concerned with innovation business
planning competition and risk and we
will be public interest political
advocates defending and advancing our
users concerns in areas such as privacy
intellectual freedom copyright and
overall barrier free access to
information this hectic and
schizophrenic framework in which
libraries are evolving recalls the words
of Winston Churchill to improve is to
change to be perfect is to change often
it also echoes what the Episcopal bishop
said to the Baptist minister brother we
both serve the Lord you in your way and
I in his so we all have a sense of which
one of those visions matters most to us
I will argue we're jockin across all of
those elements I think we're talking
about library as a virtual library as
virtuoso and library as virtuous it was
hard to come up with those three vir
work but I think they work we will be
hybrid constantly changing will be
hypodermic penetrating and will be
hypersonic fast we need to move fast
primal innovation a basic commitment to
risk and experimentation to be mutable
and maverick that to me captures my view
in my feeling about this schizophrenic
vision for the academic library so let
me pause it a theory of academic library
development I've broken out history both
past and future into several several
segments and I'd like to share them with
you and ultimately get your reactions to
whether I'm on target or whether you
have a different perspective my academic
background is as an historian and I
often use the quote God can't change the
past but historians can and so I've
taken some Liberty with that I believe
that before nineteen fifty academic
libraries were in what I call the period
of exclusivity there are very few
libraries of today we would label as
viable academic libraries there were
very few colleges and universities that
we would label today as viable
institutions and so academic
librarianship in many ways was in its
infancy for a long period of time if we
measure it against today's thinking
today's standards but it was after
nineteen fifty
after the war when so many people came
back and went to colleges and there was
a massive explosion in the number and
size of colleges and universities when
our government made the decision to
invest its research dollars in our
universities as the place where new
ideas and experimentation would be
funded and where we coming out of the
war developed this extraordinary sense
of the world as leaders in the world but
also recognizing the different political
and cultural communities which with
which we had to work and therefore we
had this explosion in global programs at
universities and the library community
in this what I call period of
popularization from 1952 1970 was in
many ways at the front end of that rapid
growth and diversification of higher
education and research and academic
libraries i joined the profession in
1972 at the end of 1972 and i look at
that period from 1972 1990 as what i
call the period of discord it was a
period in which technology was rapidly
introduced into the work of libraries
and it was very disruptive it was a
period of severe economic strain we had
great aspirations coming out of the
period of popularization but we didn't
have the resources to really advance
things in the ways that we wanted we had
new worker movements of particular
unionization of library workers and this
created interesting tensions if you look
at the status of library directors which
I have during this period from nineteen
seventeen to nineteen eighty you have an
enormous displacement of leadership in
academic libraries individuals who enter
during the period of popularization but
couldn't cope and lead during this
traumatic period of discord and if we
think about coming out of the 60s what
was going on in the larger social and
cultural and economic world we know how
disruptive that was but by 1990 I think
we had gotten our wrapped our minds and
our capacities around that discord and
therefore I look at this next twenty
year period from 1990 2010 I call it the
period of decadence it's when we really
made a mess
major transformation and how we
delivered content to our communities
starting with the sort of traditional
indexes moving to reference works moving
to journals moving two books moving to
all media suddenly we're able to present
a whole array of content in new ways
that we were never able to do before and
we had the resources and we either did
it on our own or we found new consortium
approaches to expanding the array of
collections and services that we could
make available to our community it was a
true renaissance in my view in what
academic libraries did in how we did it
so now we come to that period after 2010
particularly after 2008 when the money
goes by the wayside again and it's this
period of what I call polygamy the
period of kumbaya when building on our
history of strong collaboration in the
areas of interlibrary loan cooperative
cataloging joint licensing of content we
began to build new partnerships new
national and international strategies to
get our collective work done my
challenge is we created too many of
those relationships and now is the time
where I sort of talk about the period
starting right now as the period of para
biosis or the period of synergy I bet
you no one in this room knows what the
word para by OSIS means think of a
Siamese twin of its biological therm
where two organisms share organs and
body parts and systems and I believe
we're moving from that sort of
polygamists kumbaya collaborative
framework into a much more synergistic
para biotic relationship where we truly
not stand side by side but we stand in
essence with one another in new ways and
I believe this is leading to the period
i estimate after 2020 which I call the
period of particularism a time when deep
complementary specialization will allow
us to work together
in far more rigorous and productive ways
than we ever have before I'll be
interested in your thoughts and
reactions to that theory of academic
library development so what is provoking
new thinking about the 21st century
academic library what are some key
trends that are influencing of what we
are and what we do so I'm going to pull
out an oldie but goodie in 1995 in the
United States there were six thousand
four hundred and twenty people working
as Elvis impersonators by 2005 that
number had actually increased up to 30
8707 can you imagine and if we were
project that out what would the trend be
sutha by 2025 one out of three people in
this room will be working itself so i
challenge you to turn around and figure
out who those are so I think trends are
really important so what do I think are
really important trends for us to think
about in factored into our planning for
the future well clearly we've got
rapidly shifting user behaviors and
expectations they want us to do things
that we have never been able to do
before they are self-sufficient in some
ways with the technologies that they are
able to buy and acquire and use and they
come to us with expectations that we can
replicate a lot of that freedom and
control that they have in their personal
technology environments people don't
want lines people want ubiquitous
capacity to access information and
access services we maintain I would
argue redundant inefficient library
operations why does after every academic
library in North America have to have an
acquisitions Department a cataloging
department a preservation department a
digitization department and so on and so
on ken
we not find ways to build a more para
biotic approach to how we carry out
these core operations to free resources
to focus on our work with our user
community we have aging service
paradigms we know that there's a large
failure of discovery in many of the
tools and capacities that we make
available to our users we need to step
back and I think and refresh our
thinking about what the service mean to
an academic community to students and
faculty and researchers and so we can
reconcile but we provide to our
communities because we've jointly
licensed so much content and the
smallest library here can almost provide
the same electronic content as the large
research library there what
distinguishes us I would argue and we'd
all agree I think that it's those unique
resources those things that are
specialized rare unique materials that
we capture and preserve and make
available to the larger academic
community I see many academic libraries
migrating to a much more focus on that
unique content capability we have this
explosion in independent and self
publishing we don't talk about this and
we have a real challenge I think so many
of our acquisitions dollars are driven
to the sort of mainstream academic and
trade publishing environments and
actually last year there were more self
published works than all of the
mainstream published works that were put
out there but I would doubt that any one
of the libraries in this room is taking
focus on or responsibility for of that
extraordinary now a lot of that stuff we
may not want but we have not made that
assessment and decision we have this
extraordinary opportunity to achieve
scale and network effects through
aggregation we use the term linked data
a lot we haven't I think built the
capacity although organizations like
OCLC and others are helping us to think
more effectively about the the effect
if you will of the network of our
ability to provide our users with access
to information we will hear today about
the advanced open architecture and the
culture of openness that we have been
working on for the last three decades in
North America and we have had enormous
we made an enormous progress and we've
moved open access from the rhetoric of
the library to the rhetoric of
Washington to the rhetoric of the
scholarly community and that to me is
one of our most important achievements
having move this question in this debate
to a much more national international
framework mass education new forms of
scholarship this I think is where we can
have the most extraordinary impact by
rethinking what is our relationship to
successful graduates what is our
relationship to productive faculty how
do we make a difference can we truly
measure our success in value in the
context of where we fit in the
educational experience and where we fit
in the scholarly output the importance
of new technologies things like games
and simulations and visualization of how
the data enables us the way the data is
captured and presented enables us to ask
new questions to present and analyze
information in new and important ways we
have this extraordinary mandate from our
governments and from our universities
for systemic change to build new
measures of accountability and
assessment we need to be cautious here I
did a paper several years ago at the
ACRL conference where I talked about
stop the madness the insanity of ROI
return on investment as a measure of
academic library value and impact the
wrong tools in the wrong hands can lead
to bad results we need to be creative
and how we deal with our with the issues
of accountability and assessment we have
this acceleration of collective
innovation let's call it apps
everything's about apps on our on our
devices on the platforms in which we
work and how do we build a library
presence around those apps how do we
sort of create a counterpoint a
counterpart if you will to the
commercial discovery and access
companies that truly dominate how people
access information the new economic
context which I referenced earlier has
driven us I think to think much more
about this entrepreneurial imperative
how do we leverage our assets our
strengths our capacities our
capabilities our content our expertise
in new ways to serve new markets develop
new products and drive new revenue when
possible to the work of our libraries in
our universities we know we're
experiencing security meltdowns we know
that we're under the impact of mass
surveillance and these I think lead to
serious threats to our intellectual
freedom and privacy this will come back
in the next panel but to me this is one
of the most important trends for
libraries to be concerned about and for
us to be a voice of reason but it was a
voice of the public interest and lastly
it's this whole arena of the corporate
control of the infrastructures of of
discovery content and access so let me
let me end up here with a few ideas
about priority areas for action I did a
talk last month of in florence on the a
born digital material the cultural and
scientific record which does not have an
analog presence and I focus on the
preservation and the real challenges
that we're facing we need a true
commitment collective commitment through
digital preservation I think it's a
threat to scholarly integrity if I can't
check your references because
they're disappeared if I can't research
a topic because the content born digital
is gone then I think we have a serious
problem over the next several decades
and we're not taking ownership of this I
worked i had the privilege of working
back in nineteen ninety-five under the
leadership of Don waters on a early
study rlg on clear and it was a
extraordinary first step in thinking
about this problem and we haven't made a
whole lot of progress in my estimation
since then in the area of digital
library development we need to take the
position that scanning all this stuff is
really important but we need to
recognize that quality equals content
plus functionality we need to think
about what people are going to do with
all of this digital content we've
created and are we going to be able to
sustain it and grow it and provide
continuing access and availability over
time the academic library workforce I
think that the way we prepare our
professionals oh I think our library
schools actually continue to do a pretty
good job the number of professional
expertise that we need to work in the
21st century academic library challenges
us to think differently about how we
recruit how we develop where leadership
is going to come from what's the nature
and purpose of mentoring in our
communities several of us are wearing
and I can some reason this won't
disappear from my life I could I get
messed up all the time with this feral
professional thing but it was an article
I published in nineteen and 2005 because
I wanted to provoke people to think
differently about the 21st century
workforce and the extraordinary range of
individuals of expertise and backgrounds
that really are needed we did a
investigation of last year because I
kept saying we had a lot of people
working on staff in the libraries of
Columbia who did not have
a master's degree in library Sciences a
lot better be sure that I'm right and we
found that sixty percent of our what we
would define as our professional staff
does not have the library degree doesn't
mean that it's that we don't value that
we don't advertise for it we don't
recruit for it but the types of things
we do fundraising human resources of
digital humanities etc etc etc calls for
a wider range of skills information
policy leadership I'm deeply worried I
don't know where the spokes people are
going to come from who are going to be
knowledgeable about the information
policy issues who are going to be able
to step up and get into Washington or
state capitals or international venues
and talk about these issues that have
the hood spa the presence the political
savvy to know how to move these agendas
forward I really really worried about
this and I think we need to make a
collective commitment to developing that
capacity this is the time for researcher
partnerships the work with our
researcher community around things like
big data around researcher information
systems to help them get into the vast
literature that defines and sits next to
their areas of research focus I had an
opportunity to attend a meeting at Cold
Spring i think it was about two years
ago and we listened to scientists and
medical researchers talk about their
work and what they were expecting us to
do we were not doing and I think we're
not really stepping up to the plate here
I also talked a lot about repository
chaos we need to solve the problem of
where people put their stuff you know
used to be dependable it appeared in the
journal it appeared in the book and
that's where the reputable site opal
preserva bowl of a of a research paper
or a monograph no study was placed now i
put it up on my personal website i put
it on the institutional repository i put
it into a disciplinary repository i put
it into a national repository i put into
a format repository and ad nauseam
you've got often 10 to 12 versions of a
work sitting out there and we need to be
I think providing the leadership around
how that stuff gets organized tagged and
preserved research and development I
believe we are an information poor
information profession we have never
embraced in the appropriate ways
research and development looking at
important topics and producing
actionable results that allows us to
bring new products and new services to
our communities but also to new
communities new markets that could take
advantage of what we do we're all sort
of rethinking library space planning and
identity I often use the word Trump
Lloyd library what goes on within that
library space is very different but we
still have you know the tables the chair
is the desk I mean we still are
preserving sort of that that warm and
fuzzy feel of what a library is even
though what's going on behind the scenes
is pretty radical and revolutionary I
think we need to sort of let go of
sanctuary focus on sandbox start with
the user not with the staff move out the
books sorry New York Public Library move
out the books so that we can work with
our campuses to really rejuvenate and
repurpose and rethink of this
extraordinary core academic space at our
universities radical collaboration has
been mentioned I think deep partnerships
and systemic national strategies are
really defining the next five to ten
years how can we serve step aside from
our isolation move beyond sort of the
successful but I think maybe no longer
innovative ways in which we have
cooperated and lastly I think we need to
find a way to respond to the human
objectives of our community we often
look at you know how many came into the
building how many do surveys we do live
call all extremely important types of
investigations the studies but how do we
know as I mentioned earlier whether the
output
our work is successful graduates or
productive faculty we've experimented
and try to measure those things and try
to demonstrate our relationship to those
achievements but I don't think we've
done a very good job so let me let me
conclude Mel Brooks in the history of
the world part one and you this is an
oldie but goodie is coming down the
mountain as Moses carrying three tablets
children of Israel I have 15 any trips
and falls as we know and one of those
tablets smashes to the ground and he
picks themselves up and he gets the two
remaining tablets and he continues down
the mountain he says children of Israel
I have 10 commandments and so I've done
a lot of thinking about what those lost
five suggestions work so let me conclude
with that first commandment value
libraries what we are think about our
collective encounters with libraries
throughout our years in colleges and
universities we remember the stately
buildings the floors of books the
intimidating catalog the hush setting
the healthful library staff and i hope
the joy and freedom that those libraries
provided these elements are still part
of the library scene but the
characteristics which have defined
library i believe are being replaced by
a new vision a new vision of what we are
how we are viewed and how we are doing
how we do it I appreciate a story about
the eccentric Quentin crisp who is
talking to an audience in Northern
Ireland and told them during his talk
that he was in atheist a woman stood up
and asks but mr. crisp is it the god of
the Catholics or the god of the
Protestants in whom you don't believe
I think we have to believe in the value
that we provide to the communities that
we serve second commandment preserve our
freedoms we are constantly facing new
challenges to our freedoms when
Alexander Pope defined as the ability to
see what friends and read what books I
please we are constantly facing new
threats to the celebration of knowledge
with Toffler described as the most
democratic source of power and what
former librarian of Congress Daniel
Borstein saw as never used up for
knowledge increases by its diffusion and
grows by its dispersion that's what
we're about community standards family
values of national security political
correctness too often become excuses for
censorship and rationales to violate our
privacy so call progress and technology
too often becomes the basis for purging
information deleting emails blocking
access I thought you were going to laugh
when I said deleting emails monitoring
behavior and advancing one point of view
every snowflake in an avalanche pleads
not guilty don't let it happen third
embrace our human objectives think about
your success so the things turn out well
and you achieve and attain your desired
goals focus on your happiness what
defines for you well being and
contentment be productive and achieve
the results and benefits that you want
advance your personal progress and
forward movement and veterans take risks
but always remember that the early bird
may get the worm but it is the second
mouse the second mouse that gets the
cheese
have an impact that one always has that
ripple effect have an impact have a
significant effect forth advanced the
revolution David close in his book the
meaning of revolution notes that the
essential feel of revolution derives
from his cataclysmic quality it destroys
security and unsettles conviction
McClune says are a age of anxiety is in
great part the result of trying to do
today's job with yesterday's tools and
fifth care about each other sainik
nauseous of loyola spoke of the selfless
friend to give and not to count the cost
to fight and not to heal the wound to
toil and not to speak for rest to labor
and not to ask for reward ken kesey you
recall is the author of One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest he once commented in
an interview you can count the seeds in
the Apple oh that protects a business
owners in terms of their their lease and
but you can't count the apples 12 month
lease for 40 years and no
that's my puppet I need a prognostic
exercises offer opportunities to set
aside reason to avoid evidence and just
speculate with abandon I've tried to do
that today academic library futures I
think are particularly challenging to
define as the community of interest is
so narrow and the implications of error
error are so modest nevertheless
thinking about where we are going helps
us also to define speculation about
where we are and where we have been
there are in my view only three
continuous elements first we must have
hope believe in and aspire to expanding
relevance and impact what we do is
really important second we must achieve
power to have authority influence and
respect and third we must continue to
celebrate ideas but focus much more on
action getting things done thank you
very much
thank you Jim I think we've actually for
the first time her Kafka speak during
that we're going to hold questions for
gym until after our second speaker and
then we'll have questions for both our
second speaker is Carol Mandel she's the
Dean of the NYU libraries which includes
campus media services University
Archives and the NYU press her work is
focused on the transformation of
supporting the research libraries core
missions in a digital environment most
recently Carol focused on infrastructure
and service design to provide seamless
services to students and faculty through
NYU's very large global system she has
served as both president of ARL and the
digital library further iteration and as
chair of the steering committee on
scholarly communications for ARL she is
a member of the boards of haughty trust
art store archive space among many many
others kill received the ala s Hugh
Atkinson award in 2011 and Carol is no
stranger to Columbia she served as
deputy university librarian here for 11
years until moving on to NYU in 1999
welcome back Carol
so just a little aside Jim that was
brilliant just brilliant and and I'm
going to talk about what my role here is
today but in case you're wondering why
I'm standing here those of you who think
that there is real equity for men and
women in leadership just note what
gender podiums are built for so with
that in mind I I'm here my role really
today is where you know we're looking at
vision and action certainly Jim sorted
us to action and and he's certainly the
most perfect example in our profession I
really I I'm not just saying this
because I'm here today he really I
really think this of how vision and
action can combine to transform the
world he just set a great thoughtful
visionary strategic agenda out for us
he's really our role model but actually
you know none of us none of the rest of
us can actually be like Jim he's Jim so
I'm here to try to help the rest of us
figure out process how to move vision
into action what roles can we play and
that's that's kind of what I want to
focus on today and and I think that's
why the title of my little piece is
engaging the vision and advancing the
practice now I've just given you the
title for my brief remarks there's also
a little epigram for it it's a quote
from Theodore Roosevelt speaking to a
crowd in Madison Square Garden I guess a
few more people but I know this is an
exciting crowd to in 1917 when he
exerted them I want to see you shoot the
way you shout so my task is to help us
be as useful as we can in our inspired
state and consider how to shout take a
man
have an impact and I was like thought
about the fame and challenged that gym
set for us in the theme of this
conference how to avoid the pitfalls of
day dreams and nightmares I laid out
kind of five steps for myself and and
now i want to share them with you but i
do want to say i lay them out for myself
I mean this got me really thinking about
what we do in our world and I thought
about sort of what's the path from
expression to impact and one is and I'm
going to talk about five steps briefly
about each one what is framing the
vision to generating substantive and
promising ideas three is turning the
best ideas into road maps for I call
giving at the office and five committing
oneself um I don't think I need to tell
this crowd why framing the vision is so
important and we're all actually quite
familiar with the advice of Theodore
Levitt even though we don't know it came
from him and a series of articles about
he called marketing myopia um he's the
guy in the 60s that wrote about the
importance of framing and understanding
the business you're in transportation
not railroads you know consumer centric
client-centric not product centric and I
actually think that libraries have been
just superb at doing this I actually
think it's been a secret of our success
in the digital age and we didn't go down
that rabbit hole of asking whether the
book in the digital age we jumped right
into understanding that our business was
the documentary record whatever form it
took we've reinvent and alai brary isn't
defined as a place to use books it's
rather a place to seek and share
knowledge and I if we get into it I
don't know
I i think the iconography works for us I
think the Trump law is working for us we
know how to do the real stuff underneath
that and it's been very very successful
we're fortunate to have visionary
leaders like Jim and others of you in
the room among us and I think we should
give ourselves credit for nurturing them
appreciating them asking them to be
speakers and authors and especially for
listening to them so I give I'm quite
proud of us on the vision framing thing
we just we just saw that happen yeah and
and let's let's go let's go from there
let's go into the generating substantive
in processing ideas because I think that
is actually much harder than we have
acknowledged and that we haven't worked
hard enough at it and I think that's
because we haven't put enough emphasis
on the word substantive and promising
we're in a society obsessed with
innovation and so a catan daca deem is
currently just awash in processes and
venues that are intended to stimulate
creative thinking you know unconference
'as pecha kucha sessions that camps bar
camps a new one every day and I think
these events do often well at least
sometimes you know work for the learning
and enrichment of the participants they
must feel good we do a lot of it but
we're going to have to work a lot harder
and go much deeper if we're going to get
at the substantive and promising ideas
that are actually going to make a
difference in the incredibly complicated
world that Jim described that's actually
going to enable us to grapple with the
things he's asking us quite rightly to
grapple with and we're also i'm going to
have to cast a wider net and figure out
how to bring it
those the most substantive and
processing fish so I thought a little
about this and you know one thing is
that ideas come from people and that
means that we need to hire develop and
nurture the kinds of people that
generate that think deeply creatively
and productively and generate these
kinds of ideas we're going to be talking
today about workforce issues and I would
just like you to keep in your mind you
know what is the kind of workforce that
generates generates the substantive and
promising ideas that we need and we need
to create environments that nourish and
encourage this kind of idea generation
in an in a very productive and
purposeful way some of you know about
our work at nyu library is to create a
what we call a learning organization a
lot an organization and a continual
state of learning and learning from
itself and from whatever it can and the
reason we're motivated to do that
because we feel that we pretty much need
every single brain cell in our
organization working all the time so
that environment we feel we can't afford
not to have that kind of environment so
when we talk about our workforce later
today we're also gym raised it in
actually and this is I didn't realize
you were going to say quite what you
said but I'm saying the same thing now
about we the issue of the library degree
is going to arise but also the issue of
library schools into the in that we the
I school faculty that we need we need
brilliant high school faculty doing
incredible research and so I think that
one of the things we need to target a
little more than we have is a faculty
development in high school you know this
has worked really well in other
disciplines more kinds of research
grants junior faculty development grants
I have a plea here to the funders to
think more about how we can so we're
just we were just must have been having
an ESP moment on that actually it's
because it's the truth so that's one
so another just another topic on the
idea on the concept of idea generation I
think we need to devise you know that
camps and unconference a--'s aside I
think we need to devise more and better
venues for ourselves for our meetings
and the way that we work I think that we
need to make our professional
organizations and our time together
learning organizations and make that an
explicit goal I really commend ARL for
its willingness to try different process
in its strategic planning I think we
also learned a little that too there can
be too much of a good thing but we
learned that you know we can use it and
no he doesn't think so so we can debate
that later yeah but but we need a lot of
a good thing where the boundary is we
can we could talk about sorry I'm
talking to Elliot over there but the
rest of you we can have this discussion
together my main point is I think we
need to give ourselves the explicit
charge to generate more substantive and
promising ideas make that a goal of what
we do who we hire how we were because we
have no choice in this world so then
what what obviously comes next once
you've done that is capturing the best
ideas and and turning them into roadmaps
that's what you try to do in strategic
planning I'd like to introduce this step
with another kind of pithy epigram from
another you know old-fashioned man of
action Ernest Hemingway who warns us
never confuse movement with action so
just as we need venues in modes of
working to generate ideas I would like
to see us work harder at sifting
processing analyzing and thinking about
ideas letting really shaping them
letting the best roadmaps come forward
this is this is I'm going to say
something that will annoy some people
now but that's
my job is to get your you know
circulation going in the morning and I
would say that the dominant process of
good idea pushing that I see right now
in our community I will call the
bandwagon smart people who say this is
my idea and I'm going to promulgate it
this process does often work that has
the virtue of gaining some agreement
building a critical mass for a new
program but if driving a bandwagon is
the only way for us to get our ideas out
into the world we're really limiting our
potential for good planning my plea is
for more venues where ideas are not just
promoted but are considered compared
evaluated and modeled we're constructive
criticism is fairly given cheerfully
accepted and well used we're ego
politics and the not invented here
mentality are checked at the door so I
think that we can again in gender and
facilitate this mode of working in the
way we design our meetings in the way we
design our time together for example how
about doing more reading writing
comparison and analysis before a meeting
so that the proportion of thinking in
analytical time to talking is greater as
we really work together we have hard
work to do forward and we need to help
ourselves do it I'd like to command
another good example I've seen the the
haughty trust members meeting a number
of months ago was really a good example
of folks you know doing really reports
and analysis first not coming in with
conclusions gathering opinion and ways
to go forward getting the group thinking
I think we can do much more of this in
the way we design meetings our time as a
community together working is precious
our brainpower is a necessary
early limited resource and I think we
have to use it better choose the way we
use our time we have so much that we
need to achieve that we really can't let
movement obfuscate and drain energy from
purposeful action okay and once we've
done that let's get to where the rubber
really hits the road what I call giving
at the office what do we really do when
we're done talking and are we this is
where again the theme of this meeting
got me I did this for myself so if you
think I'm just here exhorting you I'm
actually sharing you know all my worries
with you is what I'm doing so what do we
actually do when we're done talking and
are we truly matching our resource
allocations to the values that we
espouse so I created this little survey
here's a little survey exercise let's
ask ourselves some of these questions
and and more some questions I put out
here what is my library my library
spending on preservation of born digital
content what born digital content is my
library preserving and if you answered o
our University's website to that
question go back and start over I mean I
don't mean you shouldn't do that but if
that is what you think you know is
enough I would recommend you think again
what new infrastructures does my library
contribute to I'm what new services and
infrastructures does my library take a
free ride what does my library
contribute to addressing information
policy issues who on my staff is working
on this and how how much resource have I
given to this how much human resource
capital does my library contribute to
innovation what kinds of librarians or
professionals am I hiring
and here's the one I bet we all flunk am
I paying them enough to be the kinds of
professionals that we say we need am I
giving them the time the resources and
the venues in which to work in the way
we say we want them to work I think we
can add a lot more questions to this I
think this could be a really eye-opening
ARL survey if we wanted to do that we
might not publish the results but as an
exercise in any case I think it's a
sobering exercise to see whether at the
institutional level we're shooting as
well as shouting we're taking action or
doing a chicken dance and I will confess
that I did this oath you know at like I
said out of my own introspection and it
can make you feel a tad guilty and so
let's take it down to the next level
committing oneself and those of you who
are not library directors who are
sitting here saying I didn't have to
take that quiz because I'm not ensure
you know I think that you you have you
could possibly feel guilty and
introspective yourselves as well we
really need to confront as Jim told us
whether we're matching our personal time
and intellect to what we say we believe
is the most urgent things we should be
doing so I'm not going to take you all
through yet another set of guilt
inducing questions and and and work and
have a kind of group new year's
resolution session but I will ask us all
to think more right more analyze more
carve out that time and then share the
results in venues explicitly designed
for generating and shaping the best
ideas that advance our strategic vision
use our knowledge and intelligence
collaboratively collegially
constructively see I'm following gym
with them you know
alliteration and but and proactively I
see I couldn't do that all the way
invest your time to work on those
organizations infrastructure as pilots
and experiments that you believe lead
toward our strategic goals that's the
way you can make a difference so today's
symposium is certainly designed for this
kind of smart analytical purposeful
engagement so I say let's go for so
we're going to ask Jim to come back up
and we have time for some questions
Jane's going to tell you how to ask your
questions I'm going to turn my love that
ah we have here some ground rules for
the question and answer sessions that
we're going to have today and I know we
want it you want to talk to these folks
and so we're going to have two people
one in this aisle and one in this aisle
they have a handheld mic if you have a
question not necessarily a statement
that you want to make but a question
that you want to ask these folks you go
stand in line in order and we'll go that
way and if we we have a tight schedule
today trust me it's a tight schedule so
if we feel it's going on too long we'll
have to cut it off but anyway is that
clear okay thanks so I'm hoping it's
okay for me to step up here and say
anything but yes my institution is
transitioning into an information
commons it's an academic institution
here in Manhattan dr. Neil made a
statement about library design and
moving from the sanctuary to the sandbox
I'm just curious could we not do a
hybrid sanctuary for sand boxes and what
do we want to keep and what we want to
change and what do we want
is simply sort of flesh out and and
leave fluid because otherwise one does
have the issue of territory and politics
that can really destroy and one starts
off with a budget and as time moves on
it just it gets less and less so I'd
like to see maximizing other resources
great I think I think the key to
rethinking and repurposing our space is
fluidity and adaptability and so my
provocation of moving from sanctuary to
sandbox was more of a sense of we've
been sanctuary for too long and
therefore we need to integrate and adapt
our spaces to make it possible to do
different types of collaborative work
and to partner with University offices
to really rethink how our space serves
the larger community there always will
be a place for sanctuary in the library
and I think we need to help define those
spaces but what we've learned in
Colombia I believe is that users help us
to define those spaces and really
managed in a large way of the cultures
and conditions of spaces around the
library so your observation is
absolutely correct I was just trying to
move us in that direction yeah I think I
think we're just exactly in the same
place and and while I would say we
should think about that language gym in
the sense of I think that playing our
brand and our iconography of library has
gotten us super far we're also beloved
for that reason you know that if you let
our users vote a lot of a vote for
sanctuary but I don't know that I'd use
the word sanctuary except with you know
with each other to be provocative as
you're so good at but it's it's really
the mix the mix of spaces and just
understanding though that there are so
many other ways of learning and engaging
with ideas besides just sitting by
yourself I agree we remember we have the
Burke library so we can use word
sanctuary
hi I'm Jessie from Cornell University
and I got a little chuckle Carol when
you said all of you that aren't
directors and have been ignoring your
questions but I think it's important
that people at all levels of our
organizations are actually answering
those questions and wondering if in the
idea of turning vision into action what
are some good strategies for trying to
get it so that my answers to those
questions are in alignment essentially
with Ann's answers to those questions
and how can we sort of spread that
vision and action throughout the
organization yeah and I that's a great
that is just a great comment because
it's it it's more of what I was talking
about how important our processes are
you know we absolutely were nowhere
without you know without vision and
knowing what we're talking about and
inspiring people but I think that we
just all need more effective processes
it within our institutions and when we
get together in places like this because
we need everybody's brain and we need
everybody's idea so we've I know at my
at NYU we've experimented with a number
of different formats for example for our
all staff meetings that's really going
way into the you know organization of
sort of we have the format that seems to
be working the best is kind of these
table discussions that people can join
and then switch in the middle and join
other other ones and learn from each
other that's so we can spread it really
widely smaller settings more kinds of
forums more kinds of working groups so
there's kind of no end to the good
processes that can work I make for quick
observations one I think the process
that generates priorities in actions
needs to be as embracing and
collaborative as it can be so
individuals across the organization take
ownership of the things that the library
sees is important second I've taken the
position that if you want to see a
library's true strategic plan priorities
look at its budget
too often we set goals and directions
and then we don't invest in those
priorities so I think we have to put
significant and appropriate resources
behind those priorities which means
other things don't get done third we
need a process of assessment we need to
be able to evaluate have we made
progress are we achieving those goals
what are the measures of success and
lastly I have found that providing
opportunities within the organization
for the teams and individuals who
actually do the work to advance these
priorities should have a bully pulpit to
share with their colleagues what they
have done what they've experienced that
allows them to take credit for the work
that they've done but it also gives them
an opportunity to reflect and think
about what they've done as they take the
next steps in moving those goals forward
I have a quick question I think we have
time for one more maybe in listening to
both of your your talks I was struck by
what we're not doing and I would like to
pose it posed the question to but either
of you do we lack ambition as a
profession I was hoping for a response I
don't think so I just I you know so Jim
might disagree with me but I see a lot
of incredible stuff going on I i see i
see that you know just think how we
could have not made the transition just
think you know where we could be and
instead everyone points to libraries is
it you know public libraries academic
libraries is the most you know among the
most successful parts of organizations
are parts of communities so as a
profession yes but is it penetrating
widely enough deeply enough you know
it's it's getting harder are we really
setting it up I think that's the tough
part and Jim probably hasn't even better
and no I think I think we have enormous
ambition the the list of priority
actions that I outline for example we
flex I think a common sense of need and
priority of my concern and I've used the
word polycentric to describe this
phenomenon in our profession polycentric
is anthropology cool theory that
suggests that that humans did not just
develop in Africa but in fact had they
were actually evolving at different
points around the around the world I use
that as a metaphor that there are
libraries and teams of libraries working
on the same stuff all over the place not
connecting not working with each other
so i think we waste a lot of
intelligence resources capacity
infrastructure by not having the way our
scientists work together there's no it's
rare to find an individual scientific
researcher they are part of global teams
of researchers who have coordinated a
pretty ambitious approach to how we're
going to solve the world's big questions
and we've got some big questions to
solve and we need to find a way to
connect our work in more effective ways
hi I want to start with a statement but
I do actually have a question okay I
just want to say I just want to thank
both of you I was I spent 11 years at
Columbia and Jim I was never officially
part of your organization but I sort of
circled around it and I got the
opportunity many times to hear you speak
and share your vision and it was really
terrific and Carol I now AM part of your
organization and you know both of these
individuals really do turton vision into
action and so I just wanted to say thank
you and now my question is really
circling back to something Jim said
about how we can align ourselves more
closely so you know why do we why does
every library have an acquisition
department and why does every library
have a digitization department and while
digitization is pretty close to my heart
so i was trying to even think about how
we would align ourselves i mean we
already are trying to align ourselves in
terms of standards and processes and
tools and even that is difficult I mean
everybody has their opinion about
standards and
way things should be done so how do you
actually see that happening in the real
world or is that just still sort of I
mean you said 2020 so maybe maybe you
don't know yet how it's gonna look but I
just wanted to know yes I don't know yes
okay I I think I think I think we if you
look back in the sort of earlier periods
of our development of each library
basically did its own cataloguing and a
lot of them spent a lot of times doing
it in fundamental in original ways and
we found the creative juices in order to
share that and you know I coming out of
the 60s and into the 70s with OCLC and
eventually Arlen rlg we had some good
ways to radically repurpose resources by
building upon the work of others one
could argue we've done the same with
interlibrary loan and document delivery
and so forth and I'm basically as can we
take another step can we create
production centers that take on in a
more efficient and effective way some of
the routine I'm not about to specialized
work but the routine work that is being
done in our libraries I believe that
would enable us to free resources to
apply to things like a born digital
collection development and archiving I
don't know because I think there are
egos and politics and economics that
have not that are not ready for that
type of activity but I think we need to
find a way well I think we're going to
move to our next panel so let's give a
hand to our agenda
you